echoing red-carpet moments of his past
greeted by a tunnel of press Johnny
Depp's reception inside the High Court
was anything but cross-examination in
his libel trial focused heavily on
allegations of violence due to excessive
drug and alcohol use this photo
submitted to court shows the actor
apparently unconscious he said he was
sleeping in another image bruising to
his ex-wife
Amber Heard zarm is seen she claims as a
result of a jealous rage by her former
husband an email which was written by
misheard and never sent was also read
out it's like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
she wrote half of you I love madly the
other half scares me many times you've
hurt me physically and emotionally the
monster comes out and you become mean
and horrible the opposite of why I love
you
Amber Heard was also in court as her
former husband attempts to sue the
publishers of the Sun newspaper over an
article describing him as a wife-beater
among 14 alleged incidents of domestic
abuse she claims she was kicked in the
back and slapped repeatedly on a plane
by Johnny Depp after being accused of
sleeping with actor James Franco Johnny
Depp strenuously denies all the
allegations against him he told the
court I would call a man who kicked a
woman in the back as Savage it's the
worst thing that's ever been said of me
he also said that his ex-wife's claims
were a hoax that she'd been planning for
years as an insurance policy against him
photographs of what appear to be lines
of cocaine next to mr. Depp's credit
card and a skull and crossbone box with
his initials on were referred to by
lawyers
he agreed he'd used the drug but had
never been addicted to it he was also
asked repeatedly whether he had trouble
recalling details from the past
he said no Johnny Depp looked visibly
tired after five hours giving evidence
one of his last comments to the court
was I am NOT a violent person
they'll be back on Thursday for a third
day as extraordinary but conflicting
details of this Hollywood couple's
marriage emerge in what has become a
high stake libel trial adele robinson
sky news at the high court